All right, guys, so here is an example number two for the market maker
second distribution entry model
So over here you can see that we took out external liquidity right right here and our drawn liquidity is gonna be this
Fair valley gap right there. So let's study what happened here. So remember from 15 minutes. We go to a one-minute time frame
Now going over here
We can see we took out the external liquidity which was here
Now what we're waiting for is a
Shift in the market structure. Once you get the shift in market structure
That is when you have to look for a double break of structure. Okay, you cannot look that that before
However, if you have a high high high low and a higher high
Right and that second higher high gives you the market structure shift that is valid
However, if you get a high high high high low higher high
Without market structure shift that is not valid
So you have to wait for market structure shift and then you have to wait for that
Setup
However, if you get like a higher high high low and then a higher high and the second higher high
That is formed is gives you market structure shift and that is a double break of structure pattern as well
Listen to what I said if you don't understand this. So we have our first market structure shift and now we're waiting for a
Break of structure. So that happens just right here. Now what we are waiting for is a purge on a
High low, right? So we get a purge here
Sorry here here and here now once you get the purge you have to patiently wait for a double break of structure once again
So over here, what do you see? We have a higher high high low and then a higher high?
So this tiny break of structure right here is a valid one. Okay, it doesn't matter the size doesn't matter
That's what she said. No, she never really said that
Oh my god, bro. All right, so you get the break of structure here
High high high low high high that is your silver
Like it's it's not even silver. It's like a platinum bullet here at this point because it goes way fast. Okay
So right here, this is your second
Distribution entry on this for remember to use the extreme fairly gap in this case in this leg, right?
So you have to use the extreme fairly gap in these two legs. So higher high high low higher high, right?
In these two legs, you have to use the extreme fairly gap. That is not touched before
And as you can see we could have gone long just here
That was our drawn liquidity and a beautiful trade to the upside
So let me give you guys one more example